after less than a year in office this
was Magdalene Anderson's final press
conference as Sweden's first female
prime minister
it looks like the four right-wing
parties have received just 50 of the
votes in the election and in Parliament
they have a one or two seat Advantage
it's a thin majority but it is a
majority so tomorrow I will therefore
ask for my dismissal as prime minister
and the responsibility for the process
going forward will now be with the
speaker and the Parliament the man
waiting to take the mantle is the leader
of the moderate party Ulf christerson
his center right Coalition winning a
parliamentary majority when the final
votes from Sunday's general election
were counted on Wednesday night
therefore
my message is that I want to unite not
divide look at what unites but also
respect real differences of opinion I
want to instill hope also big problems
can be solved we've solved big problems
before and if other countries can then
so can we there's nothing so bad in
Sweden that it can't be fixed with all
that is really good
but christerson's party is no longer the
biggest in his coalition
that place goes to the far right Sweden
Democrats who took more than 20 percent
of the votes for the first time having
been welcomed into the establishment by
the moderate they have perceived the
Sweden Democrats as maturing somewhat
and like
um changing in how how did to some
extent the rhetoric basically the
country has not been able really to
handle the influx of migration in a good
way there will be some changes in for
example we do before the Restriction of
the migration policy for example Sweden
Democrat leader yimi orkerson's
popularity has gone up particularly
among young people and women amid
Sweden's Rising violent crime rate and
segregation
many swedes fear the influence of the
far right and want to hold on to the
country's welcoming inclusive values
it's a concern that makes the right-wing
Coalition uneasy allies ahead of the new
parliament's first meeting on September
27th of christerson's chances of
becoming prime minister are being
Complicated by the fact that some junior
members of his Coalition don't want the
Sweden Democrats to have any ministerial
posts but with the Sweden Democrats
being the biggest party in that
Coalition there are some tough talks to
be had in the next two weeks Polaris Al
Jazeera Malmo